vous pouvez me suivre messieurs il faut
traverser un étroit couloir au mieux
rougeoyant est monté un petit escalier
pour découvrir les trésors de monique
duranti des sculptures fait de ses mains
des tableaux et des objets ramenés de
ses voyages au burkina faso en afrique
du sud en indonésie ou en inde
mais attention ne lui parlez surtout pas
d'atelier c'est pas un atelier c'est là
où je vis je vis avec mes tableaux mes
sculptures mobiles collage
voilà c'est ma vie et avec l'âge j'ai
enlevé la table j'ai enlevé les chaises
ont fait de la place d'une sculpture est
la dernière création de monique réalisé
dans son salon donc c'est ce masque de
carnaval plus de trois mois de travail
c'est les trucs dans celles de voitures
a hésité quand j'ai vu ça j'ai dit c'est
ça pourra faire des yeux pour un masque
c'est une vraie comme je peux faire des
moulages de deux cornes aussi la comcom
de quoi comme des boeufs
là il ya des vraies dents que ma fille
m'a donné c'est des vrais dans le devant
aussi c'est fait avec des bandes
plâtrées et après c'est de la pâte à
papier les aspérités qui sont dessus
c'est les huit que j'ai mangé à la
nouvelle avec ma fille ne dirai ça
pourra servir une figure mystique aux
dents sanguine violente sortie tout
droit des profondeurs terrestres
pourtant pour sa créatrice pas question
de parler de diable ça représente quoi
j'avais dit la paix mais ma fille m'a
des bulles aidé à s'implanter
ce serait pas la peine ils disent que
c'est la paix il est tellement qu'on les
ait sortis du feuilleton de la terre
pour réclamer la paix vider dans son
automobile et clame la paix la colère
bon je fais des masses qui font peur
mais bon et il y en a qui disent que
c'est diabolique mais personne n'a
jamais vu le diable non mais je pense
que le diable doit pas être vilain ça
doit être quelqu'un de très très lourd
pour pouvoir attirer les gens donc le
diable ne peut pas ressembler à mes
masques devant local exigu du centre
ville
nous retrouvons monique duranti c'est
ici qu'elle s'habille aidé de ses
assistants qui ne sont pas trop de trois
pour lui permettre d'enfiler l'imposant
masque a sorti de sa cape quelques
photos avec des curieux et voilà le
drôle de trio partie dans les rues de
fort de france